The moon is the closest celestial body to
Earth.
Humans have been gazing up at it for our entire
existence, finally landing on its surface
in the 1960s.
We’ve walked on the moon, carried out science
experiments on the moon, we’ve even driven
a car, hit golf balls and briefly grew cotton
on the moon.
So, the obvious next question is, when are
we going to start living on the moon?
For decades pop culture has been teasing us
with lunar colonies, military bases, space
hotels and more, but in order to populate
the moon, or other planets, we may need to
start small.
So, how close are we to a lunar base?
Now, let’s first clear up what we mean when
we say “lunar base.”
We’re not talking about a bustling, domed
metropolis.
We’re talking about, an outpost, a lab,
a lunar habitat where scientists, or possibly
rich tourists, can live and work for an extended
period of time, maybe something similar to
the 6 month average stay of an astronaut on
the ISS.
For the
first time in human history we are going to
the Moon not to go and come back, but we are
trying to go to the Moon and stay there, hence
we need to have a Moon base, like a base where
we could live through science, through operations
with maybe six astronauts altogether.
Only twelve people have ever set foot on the
moon, the last being Eugene Cernan and Jack
Schmitt during Apollo 17 way back in 1972.
Since then we’ve accomplished many amazing
things in space, from landing a rover on Mars
to a breathtaking flyby of Pluto.
But we haven’t sent anyone back to the moon...yet.
I think what we're going to see is a big ramping
up of interest in lunar exploration, both
in orbit and at the surface, internationally,
from national agencies and governments, but
also from the private sector and from commercial
entities.
This interest is going to be driven by science,
by engineering, by technology development,
by preparing for future exploration, by understanding
the resources that we find locally at the
Moon, and how we can use those things to prepare
us for what we do later…
You see, setting up a base on the moon may
be key to, not only understanding our past,
but to jumpstarting our future.
We can study the impact craters and geology
to help us better understand the formation
of our solar system.
We can set up radio telescopes on the far
side which would be shielded from Earth’s
electromagnetic interference, which would
enable us to better study the big bang.
And we can use a moon base as a testing ground
for an eventual space colony.
Because, right now, we have no data on the
health of astronauts living on another astronomical
body for months at a time.
And maybe most importantly, we can discover
how efficiently we can be on another world,
since we won’t be able to ship all of our
supplies.
So if we as a species want to go beyond, if
we want to live in space, if we want to work
elsewhere in the solar system, then the way
we do that is we go to the Moon, and we learn
to live and work for prolonged periods of
time away from the Earth
using the resources that
we find locally.
One possible important resource might be newly
confirmed lunar ice, which scientists think
we could use to create rocket fuel.
We could extract the ice, isolate the oxygen
and hydrogen, and manufacture fuel on the
moon, meaning lunar visitors wouldn’t be
bogged down with the extra weight of return
fuel.
Another resource is the regolith, which some
space agencies think may be the key to building
a moon base.
Well, if you wanted to build a moon base,
the sort of obvious thing is you'd want to
use lunar regolith as your basic building
material, because there's lots of it.
If you have to import your construction materials
from Earth, it's just a ridiculously expensive
thing to do, you know?
So you need to develop the capacity to turn
regolith into something useful, and there's
been a lot of proposals.
What we should do is something completely
different, that is we have to ship to the
moon a 3D printer and the 3D printer, using
the dust that is already on the Moon, so the
Moon regolith, would build completely automatically
using the sunlight endlessly available on
the Moon surface,
by baking layer after layer the Moon base
in a completely automatic manner.
Others think we could start shipping modules
to the moon piece by piece, similar to how
we’ve built space stations in low earth
orbit.
Or we could just dig an underground bunker,
tunneling under the regolith.
But whichever plan we go with, there needs
to be thick walls between the people inside
and the harmful environment outside.
The Moon can be very hot during the daytime
and very cold at night, so you need to be
able to moderate those temperatures so that
astronauts can live in a comfortable environment.
You're also exposed to radiation that comes
from the Sun and from deep space, and so you
need to find ways of reducing the radiation
that astronauts are exposed to.
A base on the moon would look basically like
a very large hill from the outside.
And the reason for that is there's quite a
bit of radiation on the surface of the moon...For
your radiation shielding you need about five
or six meters, about 15 to 20 feet.
And you've got to pile that on top of your
modules, which are probably a good 10 feet.
So you've got basically a hill 30 or 40 feet
tall.
The inside, particularly for early bases,
is probably very much like the inside of the
International Space Station.
Lots of wires and laptops and metal and storage
units and stuff like that….
But of course this very large hill will need
to be top of the line, equipped and set up
with everything needed to maintain a lunar
crew.
The major thing you're going to need is, of
course, to be able to get there, to get back,
to be able to enable astronauts to survive,
to be able to work in a comfortable environment
that is safe, but then also to have the facilities
that are needed for research and for transport
around the lunar surface.
In particular, power is going to be a major
aspect of any infrastructure.
Well, the stuff you need before you build
a moon base is very similar to what you need
for anything else in space.
The first, most important thing is you have
to be able to breathe.
So that means you need a pressure vessel,
and it means you need an atmosphere that has
enough oxygen and enough other stuff so the
oxygen doesn't turn into an inferno.
You need food.
Of course, the food needs a lot of water,
because you need water to grow crops
You're going to have to have massive resupply
from Earth or you're going to have to figure
out how to get water out of the lunar soil.
Yes, a lunar base does seem futuristic and
sci-fi, but we’re already working on all
the things required down here on Earth.
We’re 3D printing building blocks using
materials that simulate lunar regolith.
Scientists are planning missions to further
study lunar ice in order to better prepare
for extraction.
There are groundbreaking greenhouses around
the world proving agriculture can flourish
inside.
And with the rise of private space companies,
the cost of sending supplies or people to
the moon might be on its way down, especially
if Elon Musk’s “Big Falcon Rocket” comes
to fruition.
This is the rocket that is hoping to send
a Japanese billionaire to the moon and one
day carry some of the first Mars explorers.
So, then what is stopping us?
First of all, in my opinion more than a technical
aspect or a technical issue, more than that
is a political issue.
What we need to solve is we need to get all
the political need and will to do a mission
of this proportion.
We need to have not just Europe, not just
the United States, but certainly Europe, certainly
the United States, Russia, India, China, Japan,
Canada all working in a mission of this proportion.
I think the fundamental reason there's not
a base on the moon today is there's not enough
interest to justify the right resources necessary.
So, all we have to do is convince the governments
of the world to work together and put up billions
of dollars in order to advance our understanding
of our solar system and ensure that living
off Earth could be a viable option.
Oh, and make sure the base is usable, safe,
has enough power, water, food, heat and oxygen.
Seems easy enough.
So, how close are we to a moon base?
The way things are steady state, we're not
particularly close to a moon base.
People have ideas, but there's no funded project
that says, "And when we're done, we're going
to have built a moon base."
It just doesn't exist at the moment.
However, we've got these really incredible
vehicles coming online from SpaceX, or at
least we hope they're going to come online
within not too terribly long.
If those vehicles become available, and they
meet something resembling what industry rumor
and SpaceX says they might meet, then you
could easily see serious progress on a lunar
base in five or ten years.
So my hope is that within 10 or so years from
now, we would be having the first human missions
returning to the lunar surface.
So once we've done that, we can start to build
up the capabilities that we would need, and
so my expectation is that a base at the lunar
surface, based on current planning, would
become possible during the mid to end point
of the 2030s.
That's when I would expect it to happen.
To state how close we are is very difficult
for me at the moment.
What I can say is that what we need to have,
again, I'm saying this many times because
this is really the missing bit at the moment.
We need to have the will of many political
entities in the world to decide to go and
build a Moon base.
In my opinion, we are certainly not talking
about hundreds of years, we are talking about
few decades to get a functioning Moon base
on the Moon surface.
Great, where do I sign up?
If this episode piqued your interest on lunar travel, you should check out our Apollo series.
It covers each Apollo mission, from the tragic to the triumphant. Check out the complete series playlist.
Thanks for watching and don’t forget to share, subscribe and comment.